welcome to the heavy spoiler show i'm
your host paul aka michael a whole
jordan and in this video we're going to
be breaking down episode six of marvel's
what if the entry has several easter
eggs that call back to the beginning of
the mcu and throughout this we'll be
talking about the hidden details things
you missed and also giving our thoughts
for where the series could be going in
the future because of this there's gonna
be a shitload of spoilers so if you
haven't had a chance to check it out
then i highly recommend that you check
out now if you enjoyed the video then
please smash the thumbs up button and
make sure you subscribe for a
partnership between us that's gonna be
more iconic than killmonger and tony
stark without the way thank you for
clicking this now let's get into the
video
okay so the episode is heavily tied into
not only the beginning of the mcu but
also black panther michael b jordan
returns as killmonger who is regarded by
many as being the best buddy in the
entire infinity saga in the same year
that thanos rocked the universe in
infinity war michael b was picking a
best villain trophies at the mtv movie
awards and it's clear his character left
a big impression not only does this see
the return of several dead characters
such as tony stark and killmonger but we
also get ulysses claw which annie circus
teased at on his instagram the other day
now we pick up in the kunar province of
afghanistan to see tony stark traveling
back from the jericho missile
demonstration for the us government not
to get too wokey but i've always viewed
iron man as a metaphor for the iraq war
the war on terror and the occupation of
the middle east and asia don't click out
yet but listen now in the first iron man
film it was very much about a man who
sold weapons in afghanistan realizing
how bad it was though there's a lot of
people who think the mcu only started
doing social commentary recently that
movie very much set the stage for how
superheroes would operate if they
existed in real life and the issues that
they would all wrestle with after seeing
firsthand the damage that had been done
he decided to take not only his company
but also his personal drives and
ambitions in a completely different
direction up until this point his genius
had been used for personal gain at the
expense of others whereas he realized
that he should try and help the world
rather than hinder it western might is
something that could be used in a
positive or negative way and it's
interesting to see how things are
changed up for this episode with his
path completely changing now this shot
is actually the first thing that we ever
got in the mcu and it's amazing how the
creative team have perfectly managed to
recapture the scenes the entire sequence
is pulled directly from the opening of
iron man and it works so well i place
the opening side by side here so you can
see how they line up but we watched the
funby convoy as it moves through the
desert for traveling inside of it to see
tony taking a photo with a fan tony
mocked the idea of peace because he'd be
out of the job with it but throughout
the saga he changed his mind and often
used peace as a driving force for most
of his actions upon leaving the cave in
the first iron man film the first thing
he did to the helicopter was hold up two
fingers to symbolize this change in the
senate hearing during iron man 2 he also
held up two peace signs and used the
phrase peace in our time when talking
about why he and bruce needed to create
ultron this all came full circle in
avengers end game when tony fully buried
the hat [ __ ] with captain america upon
returning to avengers hq and giving him
the shield he said that all he wanted
was peace and i love how this entire
thing comes full circle from this the
first time he were introduced to tony
his hand was holding a glass of whiskey
and the subtext of the scene painting
him out as an egotistical and
self-centered character who is only
really out for himself the mcu is great
at bringing things full circle and
though it might not have been
intentional i've always loved the way
that we were introduced to tony with him
doing something self-centered with his
hand which juxtaposes his death in which
he does something with his hand that's
for the betterment of everyone yes it's
a reach but back to the episode now
after the convoy is attacked we see as
the ride is fired upon and tony flees
the vehicle to hide behind the rock i
believe he calls obadiah stain who we
learn in iron man was actually behind
the attack it's at this point he comes
face to face with his legacy when a
missile lands and we see the stark
industry's logo emblazoned on the side
of it this iconography would later be
brought up in age of ultron and one
division when wanda talked about her
childhood trauma in which one of stock's
missiles was used to kill her parents
again looking at all these moments side
by side they line up so well and it
really shows the attention to detail
that marvel have put into this show now
whereas in the original film shrapnel
from it embedded itself into tony's
armor and then cut through to his heart
tony is saved by killmonger who arrives
and throws the missile away here are two
very important distinctions as this was
the first time that a suit of armor
saved tony's life whereas in what if
he's of course saved by killmonger and
they go on to strike somewhat of a
partnership now during this moment in
the main timeline the mcu version would
go on to create a miniature arc reactor
and it does kinda annoy me that he
didn't call it the stark reactor come on
yeah get get some branding involved now
interestingly killmonger's father's ring
which he wore around his neck is missing
but we'll talk about that more later on
in the video
killmonger actually mentions in black
panther that he was operating in the
middle east so it makes a lot of sense
that he would appear in this intro when
fighting t'challa he said i killed in
america
afghanistan iraq i took life from my own
brothers and sisters right here on this
continent and all this death
just so i could kill you
killmonger was a highly decorated navy
seal and it's great seeing him back in
the same soldier's uniform that he
showed up wearing in wakanda it's one of
the coolest character designs in the mcu
for me and i'm so glad to see it back
now we learned that killmonger had
actually infiltrated the 10 rings which
were of course the organization that
kidnapped tony stark the 10 rings also
popped up recently in chongqi and the
ten rings and we learned that the
criminal empire had been built by wenwu
over the centuries now we discover
they're heading inbound but killmonger
saves the day and thus tony retains some
of his more charming personality traits
cut to a shot of the mcu version in
which he hammered away in the cave and
created the mark one armor this black
vest that we see is very important and
has appeared at several points
throughout the saga including iron man 2
iron man 3 and avengers end game it
tends to be used when tony is at his
weakest point and he needs to build his
way out of something the sound of his
hammering also appeared at the end of
avengers end game as the credits rolled
and with the multiverse opening up there
is potential for his return now in my
first video i said this might be
killmonger due to the due to it being a
bad image but you know your boy takes
elves too so shadows everyone who said i
was wrong you got me next we get the
infamous avengers assemble shot and
close out on tony's final act these are
all perfectly recaptured by the what if
animators and it makes you realize how
much the mcu would change without the
character now his first film of course
ended with a press conference with him
announcing to the world that he was iron
man here we see a similar scene but
instead he's announcing to the world
that killmonger is here with him is
obadiah stain and also pepper and happy
i love how they sneer at killmonger as
they sort of have him sussed out and we
learned throughout the episode that he
can't fool everyone now it turns out
that tony has promoted him to the chief
of security and as we know from iron man
3 happy would end up becoming forehead
of security which he remarks was meant
to be his job
now rather than learning any
introspective lessons from the cave this
tony states they need to build a bigger
and better amongst the journalists you
might also recognize christine everhart
who did a big big spread on tony in the
first iron man movie she correctly
figured out that tony was iron man and
at the press conference when he
announced it she was the only one who
didn't stand up because she already knew
again she asks the tough questions and
it was actually christine that spurred
tony onto act when she presented him
with the photographs of his weapons
killmonger reveals he knew the
assassination up and obadiah panics and
tries to shut it down however the man
has brought the receipts and amongst
them we see the ten rings logo in the
center are two swords and you might have
noticed in the post-credits scene of
chongqi that this was changed when when
things changed that i won't spoil in
case you haven't seen it now happy then
gets to show off his boxing prowess and
we journey to tony's miami beach house
killmonger is appointed as the new ceo
much to peppa's disapproval and she of
course went on to get this position in
iron man 3. rowdy arrives and we see him
played by don cheadle rather than
terence howard who of course took the
role in the original film he brings up
that kill manga was from oakland which
is where we were introduced to the
character at the start of black panther
they travel into tony's garage and we
see the set of sports cars that he has
including the hot rod on the end which
would go on to inspire the colours of
the iron man armor we discover that he's
been working on repulsor tech but rather
than being for his suit it's for a
jericho missile which has been
miniaturized into a portable firearm see
women size does matter yes sometimes the
smaller the better now killmonger brings
up his father's catchphrase that peace
means having a bigger stick than the
other guy which tony mentioned during
the first iron man film now as my wife
says sometimes it's better to have a
smaller stick paul and we see dummy come
in and grab the gun off him see dummy
knows as well now dummy was actually
tony's first invention and it was a cool
bit of comedic relief throughout the
ironman trilogy killmonger says that his
father was killed by gang violence and
later we see he kept his ring but rather
than having it on show he hid it away so
that questions wouldn't be asked about
it in black panther he has it on show at
all times but this changing highlights
at his mind state has changed and he's
somewhat hidden his motives away in
order to infiltrate wakanda through
different means we never learn whether
he actually knows the truth about his
father but due to his actions i kind of
get the feeling that he does now he
inspires tony to create a drone army and
as ivan vonkost said drone better
clearly the idea of drones was matched
by vonko who shared similar
technological skills to tony i like this
is somewhat a call back to iron man 2 to
show us where the weapons technology
would have gone had tony not became iron
man we see killmonger's design for this
which looks like it was ripped right out
of gundam and tony creates a more
efficient bot now you might catch that
the character is starting to drink more
and more and this idea of tony being an
alcoholic is ripped right out of the
pages of demon in a bottle in that tony
became dependent on alcohol and though
the mcu dealt somewhat with his mental
health issues in iron man 3 they never
out and out painted him out to be an
alcoholic what i appreciate about what
if is that even though it's a cartoon
they still go after dark themes and
there's a lot of subtext to tony
constantly ordering drinks we see him
taking the design apart and this scene
massively mirrors him creating the iron
man suit they even have an operations
test which feels like it's ripped right
out of tony testing the flight pattern
of the mark ii jarvis will be put in
control of the drones and this is
somewhat this timeline's version of him
getting to be in a synthetic body tony
theorizes building a miniature arc
reactor but he shuts the idea down and
killmonger ends up using his father's
ring which is made of vibranium tony
says his father used the last of it
during the war and this was of course to
make cap's shield in the first avenger
it wasn't really the last of it but
wakanda hid away their source and this
is why claw ended up attacking the
country so that he could get more they
scan the ring and this creates a
circular mesh that breaks down its
elemental structure something similar
appeared in iron man 2 when tony was
creating a new element and it's sort of
like poetry they rhyme now realizing
they need more they reach out to claw
who is operating out the salvage yard on
the african coast that we first saw pop
up in age of ultron it's at this point
that the us military start dealing with
black market sellers and this is the
type of thing that tony wanted to avoid
in the first iron man film in age of
ultron we learned that clone new tony
due to the machine's speech patterns and
it turns out claw has a wealth of
vibranium including not only adorama
large a spear but also several
containers of the stuff at this moment
the lights go down and it's when black
panther rolls into town taking everyone
out one by one including claw's right
hand man you might recognize from age of
ultron this scene including the
flashlights and the firing on t'challa
feels like it's ripped right out of the
opening of black panther and it's such a
cool action scene in the middle of the
episode now it is kind of heartbreaking
as well and chadwick was of course
severely ill at this point but still
pushing through even though every day
would have been extremely painful what
if has managed to be the perfect way to
say goodbye to his character and he's
left behind several brilliant
performances in the series killmonger
calls him cars and the pair were of
course cousins and he then unleashes the
paralyzing sonic taser which obadiah had
a miniature version of in iron man 1.
killmonger kills t'challa and reveals
his true plans before making a union
with claw much like how he did in the
mcu turns out that he's been using
tony's wealth and privilege to open
doors that he never could and he's been
working his own agenda in order to
overthrow wakanda t'challa and rowdy's
body are taken away and we see the
similarities between the fallen soldier
coffins which are carried by soldiers of
their country we see king tachoka
romanda and also a younger shuri now in
the timeline we were in 2008 rather than
2016 which is when i think black panther
took place i'm not too sure as
homecoming kind of messed everything up
and yeah screw you sony
screw you now we also see general ross
meeting rody's coffin and you will of
course know him from several films in
the mcu t'chaka goes to the un and this
is similar to the post-credits scene of
black panther it also riffs slightly on
civil war as he did go to the un but he
was murdered whereas here he just gets
to go home which is it's probably better
for the guy now it's here that we see
tony has discovered what killmonger is
up to and he uses the same holographic
technology that appeared in iron man 3.
killmonger arrives to take him out in
his own home and this was somewhat
mirrored in obadiah who did the same
thing in the first iron man film this
time tony is prepared though and we
watch as he activates his own quote
unquote iron man to kill kill manga much
in the same way that tony was able to
scan cap's fight pattern in civil war
the drone can do the same but it doesn't
prove to be much use killmonger says
he's gonna have to freestyle it and his
shirt is ripped off revealing the marks
that he made for every confirmed kill
there's actually a lot less here than he
had in black panther and this is
obviously because it takes place earlier
in the timeline than the mcu one using
the vibranium spear he impales tony and
does a nice pun about how he didn't want
him to make the cut
you might also notice that tony has a
bracelet on and this is similar to the
one that he had in the avengers to line
up his suit to his body i'm guessing
that this was used to summon the drone
and it's great that marvel managed to
show he was already thinking of
automating this early on killmonger
drops the great line the difference
between you and me is that you can't see
the difference between you and me
killmonger of course said just bury me
in the ocean with my ancestors that
jumped from the ships because they knew
that death was better than bondage you
get all the good lines and for me it's
up there next to things like what is
grief if not love persevering and of
course do you know what happens to a
toad when it's struck by lightning now
it's at this moment that the watcher
stares over everything and we see that
killmonger pins it on the wakundens
which leads to the us government going
to war with them every asset that stock
has is seized and the drones are mass
produced which builds killmonger an army
that can take down the wakandan kingdom
with claw he travels into the jungle
which is where the holographic entrance
is revealed claw calls killmonger boy
and this is often deemed as a racist
term as throughout history white people
have used the phrase when talking to
black people to suggest that they
weren't on equal footing much in the
same way that killmonger took claws
corpse into wakanda to infiltrate their
security he carries him through after
murdering him at point-blank range like
how he did in black panther he also
shows the tattoo under his lip and this
is something that he did in black
panther to reveal to claw the truth he's
taken before the king and we can catch
akoye to the right-hand side okay is the
only dora melange member to wear gold
and this is because she is the bodyguard
for the king it's at this point that
tuchako reveals that he kept killmonger
hidden and this action of course came
back to bite the wakandans and black
panther much like how it does here
similar to how we did with tony he's now
operating as somewhat of a trojan horse
and hiding his true intentions he lied
about his father being murdered by a
gang antichoker clearly only accepts him
because he believes he doesn't know the
truth
shuri is the only one who suspects
anything and this somewhat plays into
the ending now the drones roll in and we
see a very similar battle play out to
what happened at the end of infinity war
their power is seemingly destroyed
but this is actually a ruse by
killmonger who starts them up
and i think that this time they might be
under his control they never confirmed
that but that yeah that's just kind of
what i take from this final battle now
it leads to an epic third act in which
killmonger rides into battle against the
drones on the back of a rhino these were
of course used in the finale of black
panther and if i'm correct in my theory
then eric can't lose because the drones
are of course under his command it's
very much a false flag attack that
paints him out as a hero and he saves
akaye's life which wins the trust of the
wakundens the drones are destroyed and
killmonger stabs won through the stark
logo surmising the destruction of his
legacy
we cut to the wakandan sunset and in
black panther killmonger remarked on how
his father said that they had the most
beautiful ones in the world whereas in
that he died whilst looking over them in
this it's the beginning of a new chapter
in his life he convinces to choker that
he should reach out to their brothers
and sisters who are in dire need across
the world and the king agrees with him
this was of course his plan in black
panther but going about this way has
worked out way better for him he becomes
the black panther and is given the herb
that allows him to have the power
on the ancestral plane he sees the
spirit of t'challa who appears in his
white gob much like how he did in black
panther the pair debate back and forth
and it really shows the difference
between their mind states as we watch
killmonger suit up in the gold uniform
that he had on in that movie we see
tony's image is used in a memorial and
similar things of course happened in far
from home in which he became an
inspiring figure due to his sacrifice
the poster says only you can avenge tony
stark and a no prize is for guessing the
word play there now peppa sees the folly
in attacking wakunda and she finds shuri
in her office who of course suspected
that her cousin wasn't all that he
seemed to be now we know from the
teasers for what if that cherry and
pepper will be working together so
expect to see a continuation of this
story at some point in the season
now if you've been checking out the
trailers for what if then you'll know
there's a big avengers assemble moment
with several of the characters from
across the series amongst these you can
catch party thor to charlotte thanora
and lastly killmonger in his own black
panther uniform i think that the series
is clearly heading towards a big big
team at moment that will pull a
character from each episode and have
them come together in order to face off
against one giant threat we already know
from the first look that the strange
supreme version of the dark will be
meeting captain carter at some point and
it just makes a lot of sense to have
everyone team up to defeat a giant
multiversal enemy that could destroy
everything now there was a big episode
list leak when the season first started
off that said which episodes had which
concept and what order they would be
coming in last week's was actually
listed as being party thor and because
this was wrong i thought that the list
might be made up however it did state
that episode 6 would be the killmonger
one so by that episode it's got
everything right the list state that the
final episode would be an ultron
infinite one and judging by the hyundai
commercial we have a legion of ultron
bots that the heroes are teaming up to
destroy now again the list so far has
got everything right except the party
thor one but that does mean there's
potential that it could be wrong however
judging by everything that's going on
around the series it does seem pretty
accurate now there are rumors that
disney weren't getting the expected
viewership for the series so after the
doctor strange one they moved the zombie
episode up to help create some hype i
still think that it's all heading
towards a big team up because well we've
seen the trailers but whether the ultron
thing is true or not remains to be seen
however i'd love to see this killmonger
amongst the ranks as he's such a great
character marvel are of course known for
building their teams up bit by bit and
not only does it look like they're doing
that with the dark avengers but also the
one if heroes which i think will work
really well
now as for my thoughts on the episode as
a whole i think this probably ranks
amongst the middle of the list for me
zombies was probably my favorite with a
doctor strange episode in a very close
second however this one was good and i
think it's probably better than all the
ones below it i can't believe it's been
six weeks now and the series has flown
by but i've really enjoyed it i don't
know if i'm going to include everything
in my bi-monthly mcu binge but i do
think there are some episodes this one
included that i'll go back to every time
as it worked really well if tony's
destiny was changed early on then it has
massive ramifications on the mcu and
outside of the zombies episode this is
the one that i really hope gets somewhat
of a continuation in the second season
now before we close up the video quick
spoiler alert for some new leaks on
doctor strange in the multiverse of
madness if you want to dive out the vid
then please hit the thumbs up on the way
out and don't let the door hit you on
the way back next week you sucker anyway
there's been a big plot leak for doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness and
it says that america chavez will be in
the film and that she will have the
ability to open portals across the
multiverse she will apparently come from
a dimension in which he's chased by an
evil doctor strange who is none other
than what if's strange supreme now we
did talk about an interview with
benedict cumberbatch last week in which
he had to hide his face because he had
some spoilers for the film on it and now
knowing what we do i think it makes a
lot of sense that this would be strange
supreme anyway that's just a minor
little update on what's happening with
the ongoing story and i'd of course love
to hear your thoughts on it and the
brand new episode of what if make sure
you drop them below and as a thank you
you'll be entered into a competition in
which we're giving away three copies of
the zack snyder dc trilogy on the 30th
of september all you have to do to be on
the chance of winning is like the video
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and drop a comment
below with your thoughts on the episode
we pick the comments at random at the
end of the month and the winners of the
last one are on screen right now so
that's you then message me on twitter at
heavyspoilers if you want something else
to watch then make sure you check out
our breakdown of the hawkeye trailer
which will be linked on screen right now
we pointed out all the little easter
eggs and the cool cool backs to the
comics so it's definitely worth checking
out if you're interested in that series
if not then thank you for singing
through this video i've been paul i'll
see you next time take care peace